المشاهد تحاكي افلام قديمه رحلات على
التواب يقوم بها اهالي الضالع واطفالهم
لساعات سعيا لتامين مياه الشرب اولا وما
تستلزمه الحياه اليوميه الثانيه
على بعد يعني 10 كيلو
في مياه الشرب والزراعه فما توفر ملوث
وغير قابل للاستخدام
كذلك لانشاء برك وسدود وحواجز مائيه يؤمن
منها اعانتهم على اختزان بعض الماء للحقول
والماشيه
25 سنه واحنا نعاني من صحه الماء وقله
الامطار
وقمنا بحفر الابار الف متر ولا قطره
شبح الجفاف بدل الاهالي جهودا فرديه
لاقامه سدين بتكلفه كبيره في قريه كولاجري
الواقعه في مديريه دمت وتصلوا سعتهما
260000 متر مكعب وهو ما يتيح بعض الخيارات
لزراعه محاصيل متنوعه
انك تحصل العالمي هذا تكلفه الوقت تكون
غاليه سواء كان مزارع سواء كان همم للشرب
خصوصا بعد ارتفاع الديزل بعد الحرب
رحله البحث عن الماء تؤرق الاهالي في ظل
اعتماد ثلاثه من كل اربعه يمنيين على
زراعه والثروه الحيوانيه من اجل البقاء
على قيد الحياه لكن المجتمعات المحليه
مهدده بالوصول الى حافه الانهيار بسبب
التغيرات المناخيه والجفاف وفق تحذيرات
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر تزيدها
خطوره انغام متناثره هنا وهناك بالمناطق
الزراعيه والتي ارتفع عدد ضحاياها لاكثر
من 300 شخص خلال الاشهر الماضيه